hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website compton they're gonna be
looking at game 9 from the 2014 will
chess championship between magnus
carlsen the reigning champion and vichy
and on the challenger magnus carlsen up
until this point is up a game and they
have four games remaining in this series
nine ten eleven and twelve both sides
get to play white two more times and we
end with vision on in game number twelve
playing the white pieces so the
Challenger definitely has an opportunity
to overtake his opponents maybe tie
things up going into some extra chests
at the end of that but this particular
match we see Magnus Carlsen with the
white pieces if he could actually get a
victory this thing may just be locked up
right now with only three matches left
being up two games I think that would
just be too much for Vichy and not to
come back from fishing on if he could
pull out a victory here and that would
be incredible worst-case scenario though
he definitely doesn't want to go
anything worse than a draw so that would
be a victory for him and they can come
back and play white two more time so
we're gonna get started Magnus Carlsen
again playing the white pieces starts
out with that pawn to e4 we've seen it
time and time again fishing on starts
with pawn to d4 Magnus Carlsen starts
with pawn to e4 and vichy nons really
decided to defend two different ways one
has been the Sicilian defense and the
other has been the Berlin defense and in
this game he chose the Berlin defense so
we'll continue with that Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 and Knight to
f6 now if you just remember a couple
games ago in game number seven they
played this out to the tune of a hundred
and twenty two moves and six and a half
hours just to shiz two moves shy of the
longest championship game ever so crazy
long game so interesting to see as they
go into this game how they approach it
if they play anything different for the
first few move though they decide to do
the exact same stuff so this is the
similar Tazz we looked at in game 7 we
see castle on the kingside night taking
capture here on e4 pawn to d4 this
Knight coming back here we see the
capture the pawn taking on c6 opening up
the door for this Queen now the pawns
gonna take care of e forcing the knight
to move
and managed Crossan again decides to go
ahead and take in exchange off the
Queens here on d8 after the King
recaptures we see pawn to h3 again they
are just playing the exact same moves if
you watch that they're playing very very
quickly almost seemed like they were
playing blitz just because they were
just playing the exact same game they
played just a few days ago so we see
King to e8 a night here to c3 pawn here
to h5 and the Magnus Carlsen played the
first novelty in the game up into this
eleventh move everything had been the
same in the last time Magnus Carlsen
played Bishop to f4 and this is the main
theoretical line so both players are
very familiar with it Magnus Carlsen
decided to go a different route he
didn't want to play another draw game so
he wanted to try something a little bit
different he played Knight to e2 so
small/small subtlety in the variation
that he chose he was trying to catch his
opponent off guard fishing on however
was very prepared for this and so he
played pawn here to b6 and if you kind
of remember back to some of our earlier
videos we talked about the fact that
Magnus Carlsen actually plays a lot of
Berlin defense himself it's kind of
strange to see vichy and on playing the
defense so much himself knowing the
Madison Carlsen was so strong but now
that we see even these small novelties
that manage cross and play and fishing
on playing so rapidly with that you can
really tell that he has done a lot of
preparation in the Berlin defense and he
feels comfortable with it especially if
he's just trying to get a draw which it
can definitely be a very powerful weapon
for that so now we see the Rick come
over here to d1 Magnus Carlsen could
continue if you wanted with the same
Bishop to f4 z did last time but decides
to go ahead and immediately control this
long D file when they talked to Magnus
Carlsen he said that he wasn't quite
expecting pawn here to be 6th the main
continuation after Knight here to e 2 is
Bishop to f7 so he actually thought
quite too long after pawn here to b6
playing this Haruko over here to d1 and
from here on Magnus Carlsen took a lot
of time I don't think he was quite
prepared for all of us she nods moves
and Vishy Anand definitely seemed to be
the more prepared player
this variation of the Berlin defense so
we continue with Bishop here to a6 and
then Knight to f4 this particular game
had been played before and had been a
few years ago but it's definitely in a
high-level match where some of these
players may be familiar with it in that
particular match we see might come to d4
and then we see an exchange and then we
see the knight take here on d4 and then
after pawn to c5 of forcing at this
knight to move that over here to f5 I'm
sure magnus carlsen is familiar with
this variation thought long and hard
about it decided to go ahead and try for
a new variation and instead of giving up
any material right away decided to first
play Knight to f4 which it will allow
him to push forward if he wants to with
pawn here to e6 so the bishop comes back
here to b7 and then we see the pawn push
forward here to e6 now Magnus Carlsen
had a few different options I really
would have been interested to see Bishop
to d2 and then swing up here to c3
trying to control this long dark square
diagonal here maybe even not move this
pawn u-hall you're the only one with a
central pawn so controlling that seems
very very valuable and then once you
have your Bishop here on c3 maybe you
get your other rook involved into the
game really control these central
squares decided instead to play pawn
here to e6 and it was pretty interesting
if some of you guys get to actually
watch the live coverage Vichy and on
pretty much immediately played Bishop
here to d6 and so it almost seemed like
Magnus Carlsen had thought of this
really creative move the vichy homme
wasn't gonna know how to respond to and
fishing on played Bishop to d6 right
away and was basically telling his
opponent a I've looked at this I know
exactly what you're gonna do you're not
going to stop me in this situation so
Magnus Carlsen play pawn taking here on
f7 and then the King takes and then we
see the knight come up here to a g5
check and now machine on had a few
different options of how he could have
continued he played King here to f6 now
the knight comes back here to check
again and we kind of repeat some moves
fishing on could either continue with
this and just do a three-fold repetition
that's basically when you repeat the
same moves three times it's a drawl he
could have done that just taking the
draw or he could have given himself a
little bit worse position he could have
moved back here to let's say g8 and
tried to play on but really it's tough
to play on there's not much black and
really play for and you definitely don't
want to play another six and a half hour
match against Magnus Carlsen when he's
just gonna wear you out instead you'd
rather just take a draw and then prepare
yourself for tomorrow when you're
playing the white pieces and that's what
he decided to do so he played and King
here to f6 we see the King come back
here they repeat a few moves and after
only 20 moves we see a drawl so I mean
I'll be honest as a spectator I was
hoping to see a little bit more
I don't think Magnus Carlsen was as
prepared for this is maybe all of us
would have hope for visi not definitely
seems the more prepared in the 20 moves
fishing on played in 15 minutes
that is extremely fast for being down a
game with only four games left in the
world chess championship he was
extremely prepared Magnus Carlsen took
up 49 minutes so you know three times
longer than fishing on he just seemed
uncomfortable at the end of it he just
seemed like he was ready to go ahead and
take the draw and then to come back
tomorrow and fight his black try to even
get a draw if he could secure a victory
that would pretty much be game over so
all in all very very short game it was
only about an hour long so not a too
much even going on since half the moves
they just copied over from game number
seven so definitely looking for
something exciting from Vichy and on
tomorrow he pretty much has to go
all-out so if he doesn't come up with
something crazy I'm gonna be pretty
disappointed him so hopefully you guys
enjoyed and it was a short one but hey
you can only commentate on the 20 moves
that they give you so thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next one